all right hello folks I apologize for
that I don't know what happened with our
internet here
um but I will be right back so
AJ if you can just go ahead and tell
people about our giveaway that is going
on right now and how they can get
connected with the giveaway and receive
free prizes free gifts from me because I
want to thank each and every one does
nobody is disqualified when it comes to
our giveaway so please
AJ tell us about the giveaway while I
get everything back online
so folks
we are having our monthly giveaway
[Applause]
last month we had 10 winners
uh of our fabulous prizes of youngevity
products ranging
from uh uh the biggest hammer in a
toolbox which is the healthy Brandon R
pack
and all the way down to some of our
other products
such as a rebound and soul and
you name it uh Becca has distributed it
and she will be right back soon to talk
about it and Doc will resume uh the
important work that he's talking about
with nerves but primarily she wanted me
to let you know that you can go to
DWD
giveaway.com
and enter for your chance to win
fabulous of one fabulous prize for the
month of September that's DWD
giveaway.com and enter yourself to win
so uh the goal is to share so once you
share uh
the show with someone else
or you follow us on YouTube or Facebook
or
um Spotify or Rumble when you follow us
and actually follow through uh following
us on one of those platforms you will
gain points and when you gain points
we will be able uh to calculate that and
pick a winner from there so it's DWD
giveaway.com so Dr Wallach do you want
to resume what you were mentioning about
the nervous system
yes well it's very very important it's
kind of the basic system okay to the
body there's the nervous system the
um circulation system for blood to carry
oxygen okay and nutrition and food to
the various regions and cells in the
body
and then of course again we come down to
our defenses which include the white
blood cells when the alarm goes off the
white blood cells are the calvary and
they jump into your red blood into your
blood and go all over the place looking
for the bad guys but again
one of the major everyday
tools our body uses is the nervous
system the brain the spinal cord all the
peripheral nerves and they're very
interesting to look at under the
microscope because they do have the
myelin the white matter of the brain the
spinal cord and all the peripheral
nerves have this insulation material
okay
and
um it's such a what should I say it's
almost magical it's almost magical that
the good Lord thought of this detail and
just think these nerves are going down
to the cell in your little toe
and let's say a step on our nail or you
you're you're running you kick is
something sticking out of the ground
causes pain so you sit down because your
brain is telling you that little toe is
painful did you break it did you cut the
skin
um is it swollen uh does it have a nail
in it I mean and so this is what the
nervous system can do for you
in addition to just daily life okay when
you get excited whether it's from Fear
because you see a lion and tiger to come
eat you as the brain will tell
your your heart to work harder and your
muscles to work harder and run fast okay
and so that's some of the stuff that
your nervous system does okay and also
going to say okay there's a lot of
shooting going on you hear all kinds of
banging and and stuff uh some dangerous
time you want to be walking down the
street
okay with no bulletproof vest on no you
want to be hiding behind a tree
somewhere okay so your nervous system
protects you
from many many different things many
many bad things and it also enhances
your life by supporting many many many
good things okay and so we do have to
make sure you know everybody talks about
the heart and the circulation system
they know about blood pressure and they
know about diabetes but they rarely talk
about the brain and the spinal cords
because they really don't know they they
rarely see a brain in a living person
they rarely see a spinal cord in a
living person
and they really see they rarely see a
major nerve and a living person okay
this is something you see it autopsy you
see it
um uh Anatomy classes and so forth and
the anatomy could be in a rat or a
rabbit or a dog
um or a cat or a monkey because they
have the same brain and spinal cord and
peripheral nerves that we have okay and
so all mammals kind of have the same
sort of nervous system
and so that's why we study the nervous
system in these animals because it gives
us a clue the major benefits we can give
from our nervous systems including
defense
okay and survival
it's just magic when you think about it
and so again Gotta Eat Right you gotta
avoid all the bad foods take the healthy
brain and heart pack that's you know
before we came up with the healthy
Brandon heart pack all people wanted to
talk about was the heart talk about the
heart talk about the heart talk about
the heart
well if we came up with a healthy brain
in heart pack because we knew
that the body was more than just the
heart now the heart is obviously very
important too because it pumps the blood
around so I get oxygen around the body
and take the carbon dioxide out of the
farm far parts of the body and bring it
to the lungs and get rid of the oxygen
or excuse me get rid of the carbon
dioxide and so that's why those two were
put into the title of this this product
okay healthy brain and heart pack it it
covers
what
about 600 different diseases
it covers 600 different diseases and
then as Rebecca said we have secret
sauces
for I don't know how many maybe three
thousand different diseases okay these
secret sauces are sort of the add-on
specifically for that cell that tissue
that organ that system okay and it
speeds things up
uh when you have your nervous system
working and then you have you add to it
at the all the nutrients you need in the
health brain and hard pack and then you
throw in okay then you throw in the
magic okay
um it's just amazing so I'm thank you
for the opportunity to speak about the
nervous system because it's imperative
and I like that picture in the book it's
all in your head there's two pictures I
like one of them shows the underside of
the brain shows you the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves coming out
and they deal with like 135 different
diseases
okay and just things going on in the
skull and the upper body although the
vagus nerve the tensile nerve has to do
with your heart rate uh has to do with
digestion all kinds of stuff vagus nerve
and so that's the 10th cranial nerve and
and then of course a balance
you get the atrial nerve okay and this
vascular Branch or the atrial nerve
and then you get ringing ears tinnitus
as the auditory branch of the atrial
nerve
and the you you know what's going on
when you know the function of each of
those nerves
when you have something going on ah okay
we know what's going on there
okay so that's the whole idea of
studying
the nervous system and it was just
obvious when we see patients who had
these very simple health issues that the
doctors have missed it they would give
them drugs prescription drugs to modify
these symptoms
they never got rid of it that's because
they weren't getting down to the basic
root cause they were just streaming of
symptoms so he came up with the idea of
going with the healthy brain and heart
pack and also with the
um is all in your head and there's a CD
that goes along with it so it's myself
and Dr Milan and Rebecca the three of us
put together it's all in your head the
book and the CD
and it covers 135 different diseases
probably more at least 135
um
so this is something that every family
needs and you want to teach your kids as
soon as they learn how to read they need
they need to start reading that book you
know whether it's one paragraph a week
or one chapter a week or whatever you
sit and talk to them about it and help
them understand maybe big words they
don't know
but this is something that
um
again adds to the quality of your life
which includes life expectancy in other
words why would you want to die in your
back in the old days the average
lifespan of human beings is like 37
years old
okay right now ours went up two years it
had been running 55 and now it's 57 58
okay and then of course the hunzas is
120.
and of course biblically in 3000 years
ago in the Old Testament God said in
manager shall be 120.
so we know that's where we can go if we
do everything right and that includes
making your nerves happy thank you Becca
can you have anything you want to add to
that Rebecca
I do because most people don't
understand
the function of the nerves they just
take it for granted that they have
feeling in their fingers and then don't
have feelings
so what would cause them to not have
feeling
in like their nerves or their toes
okay well there's pressure on a nerve
someplace uh for instance if you have
you've lost the sensation of feeling in
your toes
okay that means that something is
squeezing the nerves
from your hips down okay it could be
just in your foot it could be your ankle
it could be in your knee could be in
your hip but it won't go any further
than that if you you're not feeling if
you don't know what's going on there
okay and so you can have Regional issues
you can have total body issues
and so this is one of those things where
um it's such a remarkable system I think
the two most remarkable systems in the
body uh are the the
um
uh
the brain and the spinal cord and all
the peripheral nerves okay the central
nervous system and the peripheral nerves
is one the other one is a cardiovascular
system the heart and all the large
arteries just think about it the good
Lord put an artery
okay
from the heart
into the lungs you had oxygen and then
from the lungs it went back down to the
heart and the Heart pumped it out to the
body to get oxygen
now if that isn't crazy I don't know
it's crazy
okay so these are the sort of things we
have these systems
that are in place for that and of course
the brain and spinal cord and all the
peripheral nerves all the way down to
the toes and fingers your earlobes your
eyelids and so forth skin you're getting
messages okay and that way you know what
to tell your nerves to do
you know what to do to protect the nurse
from being demolished
all right that and so it's it's not
necessarily a toe issue if you have
numbness in your toes
it could be in your lower back it could
be sciatica
okay where the sciatic nerve is coming
out of the spinal cord going down your
leg and it could be sciatica causing
stuff going on your toes higher up than
just your toe your toe can be perfect
but you're feeling pain in your toe
because something is going on in the
sciatic nerve
just below the sacred
so how about for those that are
experiencing pain Dr Wallach and it's a
recommendation to burn the nerve endings
well I would change doctors immediately
yeah I would not be burning my my nerves
to get rid of the pain we have all kinds
of pharmaceuticals that'll get rid of
the pain and still preserve the nerves
for later function okay and that would
kind of go that direction that's why we
have the CM cream
they're the same cream
and uh you apply that locally and you
can reduce the discomfort and pain and
swelling and and and
all the nasty stuff that's the nerve is
contributing to and the CM cream will
relieve all that pressure both physical
and temperature wise uh on those nerves
and it lasts about CM cream lasts about
three hours so you may have to put it on
three or four times a day if you have
something major going on there
okay but just don't do that you need to
find out what's going on because you may
have something serious that needs to be
dealt with but in the meantime just for
kind of a first aid thing so you can
function uh you do have the CM cream
we invented that for we have so many
professional athletes
okay and Olympic athletes and University
athletes and so forth
so we invented the CM cream
for them okay we invented the healthy
owner joint pack for them okay
okay and um we have uh let's see here oh
we've we've got NFL football players
Hall of Famers like Drew Pearson that
endorses the CM cream doctor while like
okay
well it's the old Ratliff but I've heard
Drew personally say that if he had the
CM cream back when he was playing
football he and the 90 essential
nutrients he probably would have been
able to play at least five more years
wow
so that's that's the power of you know
folks when when we have decline in the
body
is it's not too late to start giving
your body the 90 essential nutrients and
that that secret sauce in this case is
the CM cream that helps the body
function
while the nutrients themselves are
working within the cells so the cell can
do what they're designed to do
so thank you so much Dr Wallach for
going over the nervous system I know
I've had several emails come in people
having nerve issues neuropathy you know
some of those medical terms that are the
carpal tunnel you know some of those
medical terms that are given to a simple
symptom
to make it sound more
difficult do not burn your nerves to get
rid of pain yeah don't don't do any
cutting folks if you yeah if you can
avoid cutting on your body or burning in
the body
why wouldn't you do it
especially for something that Dr Wallach
and the science of epigenetics is found
to be nutritional deficiencies
well Dr Wallach let's go ahead and go
into questions no and we have Jill with
her hand up Jill let me go ahead and get
you to unmute yourself if you would
please you're on live with Dr Wallach
go for it
Jill you're breaking up real bad go
ahead and um turn off your video if you
would please and then the first one is
related to your
okay can you hear me now yes can you
hear me now yes okay I'm gonna go
outside might be quieter all right two
questions one is related to the topic
that we're talking about I specifically
have somebody who has neuropathy in her
hands and also in her feet she's had it
for at least 10 years she might have
said longer uh but she got it right
after she did chemotherapy for ovarian
cancer so does that make it any
different as far as the protocol or her
the chances of her getting results
because your body produces new nerves
every day
they're you know they're repairable or
you can make new ones and so what this
person needs to do is get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat nobody
I know so buckwheat no sugar no carbon
or drinks any of the diet one's got to
go and carbonated water so you can
maximize absorption of minerals and
digest food and then do you have any
idea how much she weighs
um I do not but let's go by 100 pounds
let's go buy a hundred pounds let's go
by 100 per 100 pounds
you have to stop talking so I can talk
okay per 100 pounds of body weight we
want to have her take one
um dose a day of the health abandoned
heart pack so you take a half a dose of
breakfast have it until it's dinner time
she also needs the MSM get one bottle a
month of the MSM per month take three
breakfasts for dinner they're going to
support and promote means a pair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue including the
um
the the parts of the nerves is kind of
like the the things that protect you
from getting electrocuted when you have
electric wire you can have that
insulation right okay and the nerves
will regrow okay nerves will regrow
and so let's go that direction as
opposed to uh chopping off a foot or
something okay okay so my second
question is I have a potential client
who has essential tremors and um she
also has afib she claims she does not
have digestive issues okay let's stop
there and you know how much she weighs I
do not I would say 160. okay say 160.
well she could have uh something
um well like Parkinson's disease okay
wouldn't hurt to check that out see if
she has Parkinson's disease if she has
trimmers okay
and
um let's see here
uh what was the other thing she had
she also had afib which of course
osteoporosis of the skull she
specifically told me what the essential
tremors she gets them so bad and like
you know she has to avoid things like
coffee when I saw her she just had a cup
of coffee so her hands were shaking and
she couldn't you know put it right
has a high probability of having
Parkinson's disease she also when you
have afib atrial fibrillation it's not a
heart issue it's the 10th cranial nerve
the vagus nerve being squeezed by the
skull and have osteoporosis of the skull
okay and
um so she's got several things going on
there so per 100 pounds of body weight
again no bad foods and then
um one healthy brain and hard packed per
month for 100 pounds of body weight take
a half of those twice a day for 100
pounds of body weight she weighs 140
pounds or more I'd go with two healthy
brain and heart packs per month take a
full dose twice a day and take two
bottles a month of the of the um
um
I'm I'm
FSM
yeah thank you the MSM take two full
doses of that okay and so also I want
her to have the
I-26 I-26 the I-26
helps you build the white matter in the
brain
okay and that's going to help with the
trimmers and all that kind of stuff okay
also
um the I-26 will help uh within the
messages getting down the nerves to the
local areas okay and including the 10th
crayle nerve the vagus nerve telling the
heart to beat you regularly okay and the
doctors want to do an ablation where
they anesthetize you cut you open
um put a hot branding iron on your heart
trying to find the place that's making
it beat irregularly but it's not a heart
issue it's actually osteoporosis skull
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve okay so
these are you want to do you want to do
the non-surgical things first okay and
get what benefit you can get and go from
there as opposed to going to the
life-threatening thing first so it has a
very high death rate as has one of the
highest death rates of any medical
treatment is abolition which they use
um for people who have atrial
fibrillation is not the proper treatment
but it's the proper it's the treatment
that they get taught to use very very
bad
very deadly okay
you bet and then again
um you can use the same cream and that
kind of stuff but the problem is deeper
here when you have tremors
and atrial fibrillation that's
definitely osteoporosis of the skull and
I would also look into the probability
of having
um Parkinson's disease we do have that
case report okay which goes into great
detail Parkinson's disease
it's available through the the um
coaches okay certified health coaches
this case report
and
um
it's on
Parkinson's disease and this gal had
Parkinson's disease and she was being
monitored for 11 years by The Rush
Medical Center very famous medical
school okay
Rush Medical Center
and
um the 12th year because she was getting
annual physical and we have copies of
them and it says Parkinson's Parkinson's
Parkinson's for 11 years and in the 12th
year we gave her our program with the
healthy Brandon hard pack and the I-26
oh
and they couldn't find it so they said
oh there's something wrong we got to
re-calculator or equipment here come
back tomorrow still couldn't find the
next day so okay stop taking our
medication uh go to the desk get an
appointment for next year see you then
bye okay so we have all kinds of
wonderful things right now there's one
million people in America
uh diagnosed with Parkinson's disease 1
million
there's 90
000 okay that used to be ninety thousand
that's one million
wow that's that's a big jump Dr Wallach
well thank you for sharing that thank
you Jill for bringing your quality
okay thank you
and Dr Wallach we have a question that
we didn't get to yesterday that I want
to go go through real quick so yovanda
uh just found out that she has Acro
megalia
and if a two and has pituitary
and adenocarcinoma
and wants to know if nutrition can help
um
carcinoma I get that's a form of cancer
okay
so we'll go through and do some more
research on that first part of it DOC
and then bring the answer to that uh
next you know how old she is how much
she weighs I'll get that information
from from her well okay anyway she can
have um the hell the rain and hard
packet with all the bad foods one hell
of the Brandon hard pack per month per
100 pounds of body weight
and then um one bottle a month per 100
pounds body weight of the MSM
and then I also want her to have the
what should I say the nutrients to
support the immune system
referred to specifically support the
immune system
all right and so
um I would definitely uh go with the
again the I-26
go with the I-26
and let's go there okay two servings a
day by 26a3
servings of whether it's the chewables
the capsules or the powder
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and Charlotte has a question
she's working with somebody who is 75
years old five foot five inches
180 pounds female
and this individual gets diarrhea from
products that have a lot of magnesium
and calcium
so is that the digestive issue itself or
is that from the nutrients themselves
well magnesium large amounts of
magnesium can cause loose stools okay a
large amount of magnesium can do that
and so
um she wants to
cut the dose of magnesium
okay and see if calcium tends not to to
make you have diarrhea but magnesium
can't
so cut the dose of magnesium in half
okay and see if that's a better deal
okay and then the next question is for a
52 year old female five foot two inches
171 pounds
who is working on a cold virus and
trying to be overcome that so when we're
looking at the common cold Dr Wallach
what can we do to help ourselves either
um not have to deal with common colds or
a reaction to
well they need to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed me
some oils or glutens the wheat number
around oats no sugar no carburetor
drinks even the diet one's got to go and
carbonated water and then per 100 pounds
of body weight is 171 pounds here right
uh she needs two Health abandon hard
packs a month a full dose thing twice a
day two bottles a month of the MSM so
you can take the three of breakfast
lunch at dinner time and they're going
to support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between vertebrae
bone makes bone cell including the bone
marrow which makes white blood cells and
antibodies to go eat
uh bugs and cancer cells and that kind
of stuff so you want to support the
immune system that way okay
and then we have the killer biotic you
take a three of those twice a day you
have to get two bottles because they're
small bottles killer Bionic
and um these are antibodies are produced
okay by dealing with
um
all kinds of plants okay and so forth
and so this will help support the immune
system
all right thank you
thank you Dr Wallach and next go to AJ
AJ has his hand up for I believe
somebody that's asking a question out on
YouTube
yes sir doc how are you okay sir what's
up
so
um Rodney is uh
dealing with stage five uh kidney
disease
and he is uh 5 10 and 190 pounds he has
ringing in the ears and high blood
pressure and he's wondering what you
suggest he can do
okay ring in ears what was the second
one high blood pressure
okay is he on dialysis you know uh
okay well at 100 and
what
uh
I'm sorry
what was the body weight in this guy
190 pounds oh 190 pounds okay so give
her all the bad foods
um two healthy Brandon hard pass for a
month uh two bottles of the MSM per
month so you take three breakfast food
lunch at dinner time and then also
I would be sure to take the ultimate
daily classic tablets for the Habit
pressure take through those twice a day
um that will support and promote
um healthy blood flow and healthy blood
pressure don't cold turkey off of any
blood pressure medication but as the
blood pressure begins to drop you can
still reduce the medication
and then the ringing in the ears tonight
is ringing the ears it's almost always
due to osteoporosis of skull you need to
get that book and the CD set it's all in
your head so you can see pictures of
this girl when you have osteoporosis
okay squeezing the auditory branch of
the astranal nerve very common
and so
um
everything we have discussed here okay
it wouldn't hurt to throw in the I-26
okay to help repair the nerves and that
kind of stuff too I-26 I'd say two to
three servings a day I like the
chewables now the tubals come in French
vanilla they come in
um what is it banana coconut
but also
um
you want to make sure they're getting
rid of all the bad foods okay
all right AJ I think you were going to
say yes he is on dialysis so is there
anything that you would change with the
recommendation you just gave well the
ultimate daily classic tell us I haven't
take three three times a day do not cold
turkey off of the blood pressure
medication but as the blood pressure
begins to drop you can slowly reduce
medication based on the numbers it might
take two weeks or a month to get off the
dialysis and blood pressure medication
how long do they have to stay on these
nutrients forever as long as they want
to live okay our bodies do not make
these things but they need them for
proper function Health and Longevity
okay
all right thank you hey you bet thank
you guys
and Dr Wally there's a question wanting
to know so Eric wants to wants to know
is it is it possible to
sign vitamin D and calcium and if so
what would you do in that case
well you can overdose on water
get overdose on oxygen and so
um you can't pick on those but I mean if
you're taking a lot of calcium
um
they that will interfere with the
function of other nutrients and so you
really want to stay within the
recommended
daily allowances I wouldn't double or
triple it
we're thinking you're going to get
results quicker okay I'd go with
recommended
amounts based on you know the
recommendation of the manufacturer or
that particular calcium
product okay but the Magnesium thing do
not
take excesses of magnesium because that
can cause real problems
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and let's go to Dawn Dawn go ahead and
unmute yourself you're on live with Dr
Wallach
are you able to get unmute yourself Don
I just sent you a request too we are
thank you Dr Wallach I'm having burning
in my eyes quite often throughout the
day that the the balance is just so bad
okay is that in the eyeball itself or is
it in the eyelids or where I eyelids
okay yeah
so if you have burning in the eyelids uh
you could have
um is this you or somebody else
me and how old are you sir
uh 65 and about 140 pounds okay uh do
you have any ringing in your ears
a bit
okay how many times a night you wake up
to urinate one's three times five times
uh rarely but uh maybe once sometime
okay
well um when you're talking about the
eyelids this could be the
um
third and fourth and fifth cranial
nerves okay dealing with the eyelids and
the eyes and so forth
and so we have to again get all the bad
foods and a hundred and
um 100
you say 160 pounds
40s but I'll go ahead and take two
okay 142 pounds okay I have okay
two two healthy packs um yeah two how
they bring in hard packs okay I fold
those everything twice a day you need
two bottles a month of the MSM so you
take three breakfasts eat lunch at
dinner time rebuild cartilage and
ligaments and 10 is connective tissue
you need the I-26 uh two doses a day of
that that comes again in chewables comes
in capsules comes in powder and that's
going to help the nerves do their job
better okay because you're going to help
rebuild the nerve insulation uh okay as
well as the nerves themselves we also
have octave you get a couple of bottles
of occultiv and take three of those
twice a day and that's going to help
with the eyeball itself and also the
eyelids
and then they give us a call every
couple of weeks we'll walk you through
this
thank you Dr Wallach you're very welcome
before I I almost almost lost out on
everything and it brought me back thank
you okay you bet
right
so Dr well like I have a question
um when it comes to the eyes if there's
any type of infection that's going on
whether it's in the eyeball or in the
eyelids would colloidal silver be okay
to add right into the eye
yeah well colloidal silver doesn't have
any alcohol in it it's just you look at
it taste it just like water okay and so
you can actually put in baby's eyes Okay
because there's no alcohol in it and it
will kill
viruses bacteria fungus and yeast or
penicillin only covers very specific
only kills very specific types of
gram-positive bacteria
doesn't kill all bacteria penicillin
whereas the colloidal silver does
right so why did the medical system rush
to
penicillin
it only kills gram-positive bacteria
yourself
so you have to go to them to get a
prescription and then if it doesn't work
they can give you another prescription
and see if that works and if that
doesn't work they can give you another
prescription to see if that works and
then you're at work they have a brother
who's who has a funeral home
well I wasn't gonna go there Dr Wallach
I was gonna go to then all of the good
bacteria within the digestive system is
killed and then they have to go to the
gastroenter interologist or whatever
that person's called
where folks you give your body what it
needs you give it safe things to help
your body be able to
fight off the Invaders build the immune
system keep the digestive biome healthy
using the proper supplements and
you don't have to go looking very far
because the company that Dr Wallach
founded way back when
actually has an amazing probiotic in the
nightly Essence and that I 26
Dr well like that does so much not in
not just the cholesterol that helps
build the myelin in the brain but it
also works on pathogens that are in the
digestive system
and it helps to clear up that gut brain
connection that if the gut's off the
brain doesn't function very well so I
really recommend the I-26 also Dr
Wallach I know that you do and I also
know Dr Wallach that you have another
program to get to so thank you so much
for joining us great show you get a
triple triple A Plus today thank you
thank you Becca and thank you team and
to thank everybody all our callers thank
you thank you thank you
all right and thank you ever
we've got some double thumbs going
everybody and we'll talk to you later
doc okay bye-bye
and if I could get my co-hosts on the
screen with me I just we couldn't do
this program without a team folks as we
experienced a little bit of technical
difficulties they were able to carry it
out bring us back and we continued on
with the show so I just want to do a
special thank you Marilyn for all that
you do and putting the dictation into
the chat as you are on your own on that
one today thank you so much you did a
fabulous job and folks that's one of the
biggest benefits of being here live with
us in the zoom is you are able to open
up that chat submit your questions see
the answers that Dr Wallach gives for
the questions that are asked on the
program because of the skill that
Maryland brings to our team and that is
with the dictation and fabulous typing
and we also have Albert who is going
through he is taking and giving me
screenshots and sending them to me so as
questions are asked in the chat here in
the live Zoom I'm not missing them with
all the fabulous information that
Marilyn is putting up and he's letting
people in and he's keeping an eye on the
room to make sure that we keep it a safe
place so thank you Albert for all that
you do and AJ my assistant production
manager who is making sure that all the
streams are working properly he is
monitoring the different platforms that
we have our program going out to and
bringing questions in from the field and
doing a great job at it so I just want
to thank all of my team we miss those
people that are not here with us but
they are still with us in spirit and
still helping us keep the program
running smoothly as there's more than
just what you see on screen going on
folks here so if you have skills that
you would like to bring to a team that
is working together with a greater
purpose than yourself
one that is helping people
meet their physical needs
and then meeting financial needs as well
then you're in the right place reach out
to us or the person that shared this
program with you you can reach out to us
by going to daily withdoc.com use that
contact us but that is for people who
are not working for anybody with anybody
you have not spoken with anybody about
youngevity Dr Wallach or this program
nobody refers you you found it on your
own because we want to maintain the
Integrity of this program and be a
resource an amazing community
you can also call us at
855-949-3377 as I do have a team that is
standing by to take calls as well
my name is Becca Dukes I is my honor and
privilege as the leader of this team
working with critical Health news and
the critical Health news team also the
daily with Doc team and also with the
Institute of holistic health as I am the
director of student services where we
are training people in the four areas of
Health how they're affected by
nutritional deficiencies and
how to take those
effects that are not favorable that are
preventing you from being able to live
that optimal life and use the youngevity
products as a solution to help you
overcome folks if you would like more
information about our coaching program
either for yourself as a coach or to be
coached you may reach out to us through
the website to be coached use that
contact us or for more information for
you to be a coach go to coachwith Doc
that's
coachwithdeoc.com and you'll find out
more information about our coaching
program so until next time we will see
you Monday through Friday from 12 to 12
50 p.m Pacific time here at Daily with
Doc
zoom.com that is daily with Doc zoom.com
bye for now
[Music]
foreign